（ドアの開く音）
ついに手に入ったぞ
任天堂2DS
どれだけ待ったことか・・・
クレジットカードが上限いってて
支払いが出来なくなって、届くのが遅くなったなんて口が裂けても言えねぇぜ
素晴らしい・・・
この箱のフォルム、堪らんでゴザル　堪らんでゴザル
（包装を取る音）
（箱をひっくり返す音）
おお　リザードン
（箱の中身から物を取り出す音）
（不穏な音楽）
これが2DS・・・素晴らしい！折り目がない！
値段を押さえる為に少しチープなインプレッションは否めないか・・・
スケルトゥンボディが堪らぁん
昔のゲームボーイを彷彿させる・・・
さぁて、早速ポケモンでもするか
ちょっと待ってよ！
誰だ！
はっ
ま・・・まさか！
そう・・・そのまさかよ
お前・・・いつから言葉を！
知らないわ　気が付いたら自分でパカパカ出来るようになってたわ
それよりも何よその子！
あの・・・これは今届いた2DS
あなた・・・私と一緒に過ごした日を忘れたの？
一緒にモンハンも徹夜でしたし　ポケモンもした
キタ――――――
エロサイトも一緒に調べたじゃない！
あなたにはあたししかいないのよ！
そいつは折りたたむ事が出来ない私の劣化版よ！
おい・・・何もそこまで言わなくていいだろ
聞き捨てならんな
2DS・・・お前、箱との摩擦を利用して音声を出しているのか！
そうさはじめ、買ってくれてありがとう
うん　えへへ
はじめ！何デレデレしてんのよ！
はじめよ、お前は3DSの3D機能を使ったことはあるか？
正直に言おう・・・俺は・・・3D機能を・・・
使いたいと思ったことはない！
はっ
はっはっはっはっはその通りだ　貴様の3D機能は必要とされていない！
そんな・・・はじめ・・・（泣）
あっはっはっはっはっはっは
うるせぇなゲーム機ども　静かにしろよ！
ゲームだろ！なんで俺ん家で勝手にゲームばっか喋ってんだよ
静かにしてくれよマジで、ホントに迷惑なんだけど早く帰ってくんね？
（ドアを開ける音）
うるせぇぞお前ら！
すみませんでした～！！！！